so ich habe alles was ich brauche ich
hatten schwert und ein ding halt deine
schnauze q/q freunde ich bin back in
deutschland nach einer new york reise
hey ich hab ja in dem video heute
nachmittag schon angekündigt dass heute
noch ein zweites video kommt da dieses
video heute nachmittag sei wie es mit
unbekannten war und das war so kurz und
hey ich verlinke euch das mal hier
wenn ihr das sehen wollt war ein
bisschen peinlich aber wenn ihr oder
oder ihr bleibt einfach dran und schaut
euch mal im oder wir fangen einfach an
dass das video heute so spät kommt ich
bin mega jet lag ich bin auf 16 uhr
aufgewacht aber wir fangen einfach an
und zwar habe ich eine website entdeckt
die games like minecraft heißt und
deswegen habe ich mir da drei level
erreicht wieder raus gesucht wo ich
einfach mal dachte ja ich habe noch
keine welt deswegen treten und seine
neue welt klicken einfach auf create
world
anscheinend müssen wir die welt benennen
deswegen denn wie sie einfach welt was
ein super kreativer name
das ist auf jeden fall geilich start in
die welt und ob direkt auf einmal die
hälfte meiner leben verloren
okay wir können anscheinend rumlaufen in
dem bdsd drücken und wenn ich was
abbauen möchte kann ich einfach hier
diesen cursor hinziehen
und dann brauche ich das ab und dann ist
das das spiel ist fucking langweilig
bisher es passiert nichts es gibt nicht
mehr mops aber okay wir holen uns
erstmal hier so ein bisschen wie sehe
ich eigentlich aus mentaltrainer
keyboard okay ich drücke dies gerade
schief okay wir können jetzt rein
theoretisch nee da kommt nichts raus was
ist wenn ich mal hier so ok wurden place
okay das heißt wir haben jetzt aus einem
vierten platz bekommen kann ich aus dem
boden klenk dass irgendwas machen aber
es kann nicht längs backdrop machen und
wenn ich die hier jetzt hinziehe was
kann ich tun konnte kräftig day will das
ist ja echt wie minecraft es ist einfach
genau wie minecraft ok wo setzt ihn
jetzt in kann ich den irgendwie bitte
darauf zu wie geht das nicht was bringt
ein crafting teile wenn ich nicht darauf
zugreifen kann
ich bin drin das ist total verwirrend
man muss immer auf rechts rücken damit
es überhaupt man irgendwie reagierte gut
was können wir jetzt hier machen es ist
wie eine mischung aus minecraft und
terrarien scheiße einfach ich kann zwei
blöcke hochspringen guckt ihn als ist
das denn so ich habe alles was ich
brauche ich habe ein schwert und ein
dings auf
halt deine schnauze goethe sie macht
doch mein gott hat mich diese fucking
cougar gerade erschreckt das kann nicht
sein als ob mops einfach so weil sie
sind ja es gibt sogar ertrinken
möglichkeiten was ist das hier unten
ok ja ich will auf jeden fall anderes
spiel der das video heißt drei spiele
wie minecraft wenn ich jetzt sagen wann
wir das mit diesem spiel und gehen jetzt
in ein anderes spiel wie kraft autoplay
wir spielen das kommende spiel das
direkt auf hart wir sind ein ganz neues
sagte köhler
was muss denn die machen muss ich
einfach diese sachen da
oh my fucking gott ok anscheinend ist
dieses spiel so aufgebaut dass sich
diese dinge hier töten muss
beziehungsweise kaputt machen muss also
dass sich items bekomme weil wenn es
dunkel ist spawnen ganz viele böse
monster wie beispielsweise der kripo
dahinten alter meine maus ist total
verrecken bei diesem spiel das ist ja
unfassbar meinem aus island ich bin ja
nicht nur am drücken
dick tippscheine staaten war das game
mal schauen ob david input messe die
firma aus only controls keyboard kommt
komme ich machen muss ordentlich muss
nicht wieder meine hand hier nutzer kann
mit der anderen hand schön einen
runterholen
um die maus zu direct jbg okay das habe
ich ihn gekriegt click to use the bombs
okay das ist das spiel ich muss mich
hier in seiner übrigen grafik einfach
irgendwie durch graben und wie kann ich
überhaupt besetzen gewesen dass jemand
wie komme ich nochmal besetzen wie wie
kann ich vom besetzen hallo hallo hallo
hallo hallo sagen wir mal jemand wie
capcom besetzen wie wie geht das denn
okay ich habe jetzt hier upgrades kaufen
können und ob ihm eine mach ich mal und
dann mach ich noch ihr manchmal okay ich
habe drei kohle konflikt to use okay ich
habe jetzt hier rein theoretisch eine
bombe
das heiße draht 104 das heißt wenn ich
jetzt rein theoretischen den bommel
das gros gerade okay das heißt dass
viele spielt ist dass ich mir so viele
ressourcen wie möglich irgendwie
zusammen grabe um mir dann nachher quasi
sachen zu kommen wie beispielsweise
sondern bombe die ich jetzt gerade
eingelöst hat deshalb werde jetzt
erstmal auf dich auf die jagd nach kohle
gehen und mit dem zeit kommen geschaffen
ja ok damit noch die zeit bekommen jetzt
schnell die zeit habe ich noch ne bombe
megavolt nämlich nicht aber komm jetzt
kommen wir müssen unbedingt die zeit am
von hohem druck da noch die zeit geholt
jetzt da hinten ist auch wieder zeit
damit uns auch wieder die zeit ohne dann
müssen wir quasi immer voran kommen
dadurch dass wir die zeit
naja okay doch ganz schnell wir müssen
unbedingt noch eine kohle wohl kaum so
knacki was bringen mir bohne baut das
was das bringen wir kommen ich kann mir
das hier alles noch nicht kaufen jetzt
werde ich einfach mal hier wo die ganzen
gold sachen sind bagger eine pole eine
zeit auf diesem spiel nur aus derzeit
besteht jetzt kann ich mir nicht mal
mehr eine bombe kaufen ist und
langweilig freue mich wird aber auch
sagen dass wir damit das video hier
beenden mit diesem spieldiktat einer
wieso eigentlich keine
wenn euch das video gefallen würde ich
mich unmengen dollar bei der bewertung
freuen war ich locker nochmal sonst
games minecraft wieder machen könnte
weil es bei dieser website einfach so
1000 spiele gibt oder so toll dass wir
bei dem ersten spiel so lange gehadert
haben weil das spiel in echt spaß
gemacht das erste und sonst will ich
sagen sehen uns in diesem video wieder
tschüss